joining me to talk about all things
baseball including that remarkable night
in Anaheim on Friday night it's one of
our favorite people from the world of
baseball MLB Network featuring the
Dodgers and Phillies tomorrow and the
Rays and Yankees on Thursday night MLB
Network is the exclusive television home
for the Baseball Hall of Fame induction
ceremony this Sunday at 1:30 p.m.
Eastern live from Cooperstown the great
Al Leiter back on the program how you
doing al hello rich I'm doing well it's
been too long since I have heard your
voice um before we get into all the
stuff from the Hall of Fame and and
everything going on from the second half
of the season I just want to give you
the floor and what we saw in Anaheim in
Southern California Friday night were
Tyler Skaggs the on the eve of what
would have been his 28th birthday
everybody learned his 45 his mom throws
a remarkable pitch for a first first
strike ceremony Lily a softball coach
here in Southern California and and they
score seven in the first and throw a
combined no-hitter now I'm wondering if
where that ranks and stuff that you Fe
personally witnessed as a player or a
broadcaster wow so seriously emotional
to say the least the after the fact of
all the numbers and the coincidental or
not or some bigger power that we can
explain of how it actually played out is
beyond is beyond the belief that that
something was and else in in in in the
building
you know III got a chain you ask rich
you know was there anything you know
similar motion I was doing some games
for the Marlins a few years ago and I
just so happened here through the YES
Network and Fox bought the YES Network
etc and I was doing very few games and
it turned out it was the at the end of
the year the Mets came in Miami and I
had the Met Series and you know the Jose
Fernandez boat accident I was there you
know they canceled the game and I'm
doing the the game the next night and to
think of that moment not to take away
from Tyler skies and what happened on
Friday with the Angels because it was
amazing but Dee Gordon who had
had a home run in like two years leads
off the game uses his bat uses his
helmet and and hits a home run and
crying around the bases you know I'm
doing the game with Rich Walt's like
it's one of those you can't say a word
to even remotely describe what the heck
just happened and here Dee Gordon is
playing the Mariners for the game on
Saturday against the Angels he's in the
in the house all of the great tribute to
you know honor
Tyler Skaggs and you know the uniform
number and all of then after you find
out about his birthday and the last time
its no-hitter and to come the
combination and you know what trout hit
the ball 457 feet he's it's 45 etc etc
the mom mails a strike as you say like
wait a minute like how does it happen
III don't know rich you know he loved to
you get into religion or power or being
but you know I believe somebody's
watching yeah I I fully agree and I I'm
the one who brought it up about other
other situations you might have seen
it's interesting Giancarlo Stanton upon
the passing of Skaggs instagrammed out a
message to the angels about how best to
deal with the loss of a teammate like
this that you're gonna walk through his
locker and see his empty locker you're
gonna walk when you walk through the
locker room and how difficult that is
and he brought because he lived through
the you know the experience of losing a
teammate of Fernandez and in particular
with the with the Marlins I mean you
really can't put anything it's amazing
how this works out in baseball now
obviously it is amazing what an edit was
and the pace of it too rich as you know
and I know you cover you know football
and all the other respective sports but
the fact that there isn't a clock you
can take as much time as you want and
you know really you know in this case
you know honor the Memorial of you know
Tyler Skaggs or whomever else I know you
grew up a Yankee fan I can visualize to
this day when Lou Piniella was crying
and Reggie Jackson in the outfield
Munson and Bobby Mercer has an amazing
day with Thurman Munson you know like I
couldn't imagine in season something as
tragic as what we're talking about and
how to try to get through the rest
the year I remember as a little guy I
remember watching that and seeing the
Munson's uniform you know placed behind
home plate yeah yeah I mean they're kind
of you know the hair you know raised on
the back here and that kind of stuff
it's a areas amazing outliner MLB
network hero and the rich eyes to show
how great his trout man how great is
this guy
he's he's one of the greatest of all
time and I know it's difficult to say
stuff like that but um I have no I
didn't stutter he's one of the greatest
I've ever seen
oh yes yes right and what's beautiful
about this is in my opinion he plays the
game I won't say right because I don't
open up like old school new school and
all this other garbage that people might
insinuate but he plays the game hard how
about that he plays the game with great
effort all the time and he is
exceptional on both sides of the ball he
plays hard every single time he gets out
there I did a game a couple years ago at
the ester Network at Mike okay and the
angels came in at key Stadium and it was
the third out of the inning flyball the
right field errant judge is catching it
and I didn't bother to watch Aaron judge
of the fly ball or where it was going a
little bit to the right of Aaron judge I
watched Mike Trout and he busted out in
the box it's a fly ball rich it's not a
line drive he busted out of the box and
I'm watching him all the way and by the
time Aaron judge caught the ball Mike
Trout was almost at second base I'm not
kidding you I go on the box I went back
to John Moore and I said hey when we
come out of this can we just show that
like I just I can't celebrate that
enough because that's what I appreciate
and I think most fans appreciate Al
Leiter here on the Rich Eisen show okay
let's let's let's turn to the second
half of the season here I mean we've got
a race in the NL Central
you know the A's and the Indians are
trying to make races out of the AL West
and AL Central how how do you see the
rest of this second half of the season
going a liar
I find this intriguing greatly with
respect to we have about two and a half
weeks for the trade deadline it has a
hard deadline now because you know the
waiver trade deadline for you know not
having a non waiver I'm looking at the
team's rich and I count up of what I
would consider sell sell 10 of the 30
teams
that is outstanding for Major League
Baseball you look down the wild-card if
you're you know north of San Francisco
yeah Pittsburgh I think is teetering
right there at three and a half San
Diego's three back Colorado game and a
half Arizona Game and a half st. Louis
in Milwaukee pushing on Washington and
Philadelphia that is great if you're in
any one of those fan bases you have to
be saying hey we're buyers we're not
selling the second wild-card has been
fantastic I do believe that I think you
mentioned the A's is a tremendous story
you look at both of the wild-card teams
here they're not two two hundred million
dollar payroll teams contrary the A's
and what Billy Beane does in Tampa Bay
year in and year out they know who to
pick up they have a great algorithm with
respect to their analytics and great
Scouts to bring in under undervalued
players and here they are once again
playoff discussion or possibly playoffs
Indians I think was really intriguing
and now they become a bi team along with
the Red Sox of course they're going to
stay it I think Texas what John Daniels
have done so overall I'm excited forget
about you know even you know after you
know they've down the stretch in
September which of these teams actually
believe that a player here or there is
going to make the difference for them to
be in the postseason and you know this
and I know it you get in the postseason
you have two hot pitchers and a couple
arms out of the bullpen yeah you can you
can you can get pretty deep in the
playoffs you can and by the way for the
NL wildcard right now with all due
respect everybody else I you know I kind
of freeze it right now which is Bryce
Harper and Philly walking into
Washington to try and play a one game or
that would be what we talked about a
crucible if something like that happened
right but you also have you know within
four games let's say foot within five
games
Cincinnati San Francisco Pittsburgh San
Diego I mean wow you once are coming in
from the cold Colorado Arizona st. Louis
in Milwaukee it really is lit the
question I have for you al is is which
team out of everybody needs has to has
to get that big arm pitcher I mean that
the Red Sox wanted took Cashner off the
board
from Baltimore over the weekend they
struck early which team do you think
needs to get that big arm to win the
World Series right now that's a good
question that and I think that needs
part would have varying degrees yes if
you're telling me of the available
starters let's go with Stroman or Zack
wheel or a Bumgarner or you know a mat
boy from Detroit you know any one of
those guys barring that they're not
pitching like a four or five would be a
welcome sight at any of the teams right
including the New York Yankees including
the Houston Astros Astros are intriguing
to me because of you know with Brad
peacock it has gone down and Wade Miley
is emerging right and most recently we
know it's Verlander Gerrit Cole but
they're in need and here you know their
first place by six games over Oakland
they could use a starter
I've been Yankees I'm a hundred percent
convinced that they're going to go out
and get somebody to really you know just
make them even that much harder to beat
I do believe that the Yankees go on to
the World Series the way it is right now
the Yankees I think we're going to go
back to 1981 and 78 rich and see a
Yankee Dodgers and Wow World Series a
lot of course can happen but the Dodgers
to me are just too good too deep and the
Yankees are just only going to get
better can I get the 78 version not the
81 version that is 25 Winfield oh my
gosh Louisiana lightning yes one of the
best I have ever seen period a story T
what was he 180 pounds soaking wet - oh
I think it was 174 well speaking of
throwers here your son Jack Leiter
committed to Vanderbilt which is again a
dirty word in my own household right now
with a College World Series but that's
okay that's okay it's alright it only
happens with from Michigan once every 35
years you know whatever it's okay but so
your son was drafted by the Yankees was
there any chance of him saying yes to
that no but I appreciated what they took
huh they took a flyer on Jack Leiter
just in case he might just come out and
want to play for the Yankees
yeah listen it would it
very nice I got drafted out of high
school I did sign with the Yankees you
know there was probably nine or ten
teams from what my understanding was
they were gonna you know do it you know
draft him out of being part of his high
school you know life if you will damon
Oppenheimer who was the scouting
director for the Yankees who I really
like and there's a gentleman and his
class
you know I picked them and the 20th pick
listen this is what it came down to rich
as a father I was able to separate money
it was a life decision for my son and I
can tell you he was all in he wanted to
go to college he wants the experience
and every facet of what the college life
is all about and he's a smart kid so I
know there's risk but this is what my
wife and I wanted and ultimately you
know with Jack making the decision this
is what he wanted well I know you cut
back from your work and I do miss you
calling games on on yes to spend more
time on this front what's that been like
for you oh so I didn't miss a game and
it's been fantastic the 12 years I spent
the day I retired with the Yankees John
Filippelli asked me to do games I
thought he was talking about the
following season and less than two weeks
I was doing a game of Michael Kay and
Jim Cotts and there there I went with
the YES Network but it was it was even
though it was limited games rich it just
when you do a game and you're scheduled
do games it's different than what I do
at MLB Network because we have such a
variety of shows and I can do an early
show excetera
right and I didn't want to miss his
senior so luckily and I'm grateful to to
so many levels that I didn't miss any
games I was able to watch all of it and
rich it was much better than any World
Series performance that I did or any
kind of stuff that I actually was able
to do in the game to watch my kid and
all of the you know exciting attention
that was around his starts and yeah you
can't take this stuff back don't know
you're a parent like that matters and if
you're able to do it and I'm grateful
for it I didn't want to miss it well I
mean that kind of brings our
conversation full circle out I mean
life's short and and you got to focus on
what's important in life and being there
for your kid if you can and
lucky enough to be able to pull it off
go for it and I'm thrilled for you you
know how I thank you
you know thank you and have you spoken
to Kay lately I communicated with him
cause he's not talking right now because
it is he's not talking I told him to go
stay in the hospital extra days he said
he's only to be there one day and then I
said to go on vacation and to get away
and you know he needs to yeah if I were
him I'd have gone to an island or a
cabin and say we go to the Bronx what do
you do know and you can stay at my place
well out great chat with you great chat
with you love your work and let's chat
again real soon yes thank you that's out
Leiter Al Leiter 22 on Twitter for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app